Німецька політика загалом вважається чесною і прозорою.
За даними Transparency International, Німеччина - у топ-десятці найменш корумпованих країн світу.
Щоправда, парламент Німеччини нещодавно сколихнула низка скандалів,
які дуже обурили німців. Як наслідок кількох депутатів Бундестагу
від консервативного блоку канцлерки ФРН Анґели Меркель позбавили мандатів.
Народних обранців спіймали на тому, що вони буцімто отримували хабарі
від уряду Азербайджану в обмін на підтримку дій Баку.
Інші депутати наживалися на угодах з виготовлення або постачання захисних масок під час пандемії.
Тож, багато хто вважає, що Німеччині потрібні жорсткіші закони,
аби контролювати своїх політиків.
Те, що сталося протягом останніх тижнів у Німеччині, - це величезна загроза
для довіри громадян до своїх політиків. Це те, що відверне багатьох людей від політики.
І це величезна проблема. Ми не можемо цього допустити.
І це, на мою думку, велика небезпека для демократії.
Отже, що можна, а що не можна робити політикам у Німеччині?
Німецькі депутати отримують зарплату
близько 10 тисяч євро на місяць - до вирахування податків.
Їм також дозволяється заробляти гроші поза парламентом.
Близько третини німецьких депутатів мають також інші джерела доходу.
Вони зобов'язані задекларувати, скільки вони заробляють "на стороні",
якщо їхні додаткові заробітки
становлять понад 1000 євро на місяць або 10 тисяч євро на рік.
Але вони не повинні декларувати точну суму -
і верхньої межі таким надходженням немає.
Депутати також мають повідомити, якщо їм належить понад 25 відсотків якоїсь компанії.
Але їм не потрібно розкривати, чим займається компанія,
з якими іншими фірмами ведеться бізнес чи скільки все це приносить прибутку.
Критики кажуть, що це створює занадто багато можливостей для конфлікту інтересів.
Якщо в Німеччині є правила, люди загалом дотримуються цих правил.
Але якщо немає якоїсь норми, звичайно,
люди не обов’язково слідують моральним зобов’язанням,
а користуються цим на свою користь.
Нині у кодексах поведінки членів парламенту є багато прогалин.
Поки існують ці лазівки, знайдуться люди, які намагатимуться цим скористатися.
Уряд визнав, що потрібно змінити ситуацію.
Головні партії вже розробили пропозиції для посилення законів.
Але критики кажуть, що ці заходи все ще занадто слабкі.
Торік Група держав проти корупції Ради Європи (GRECO) закликала уряд Німеччини
встановити жорсткіші правила щодо прозорості.
У доповіді зазначається, що парламенту необхідно посилити заходи
із запобігання конфлікту інтересів, а також вказано на ще одну проблему
німецької політики - лобізм. Лобісти працюють у коридорах влади,
використовуючи різні важелі впливу на політичні рішення.
Вони можуть представляти величезні компанії або цілі галузі,
а також поодинокі кампанії для досягнення якоїсь мети чи вигоди.
Лобізм сам по собі не є чимось поганим у представницькій демократії.
Групи інтересів мають прямий контакт з політикою.
Але якщо ми як громадськість не знаємо, хто і як вплинув на закон
під час його ухвалення, врешті-решт ми не можемо перевірити, чи всі інтереси були почуті.
Німеччина не має офіційних даних про лобістів: хто і як впливає на якісь
законодавчі рішення і скільки часу та грошей на це витрачають.
Порівняно з багатьма іншими західними країнами, такими як Великобританія,
Франція, Канада, Ірландія, Нідерланди, навіть Австрія, відома своєю корумпованістю -
Німеччина справді не має багато правил.
Нещодавно урядова коаліція Німеччини погодилася створити реєстр лобістів.
Це змусить їх вказувати, на кого вони працюють.
Подання неправдивої або неповної інформації може коштувати
до 50 тисяч євро штрафу. Але цей реєстр не вимагає від депутатів повідомляти,
з ким вони зустрічаються і скільки вони отримують за лобізм.
Експерти кажуть, що ця пропозиція - крок у правильному напрямку,
але треба рухатися ще далі.
Врешті-решт те, що ми отримаємо з цим реєстром лобістів, -
це перелік імен тих, хто лобіює. Але нам бракує решти інформації.
Якщо ви хочете прозорості, але ви не повністю її вимагаєте,
тоді у вас не буде просто половини прозорості. У вас не буде її взагалі!
Канцлерка Анґела Меркель має намір піти з політики після вересневих виборів,
тож Німеччина вступає у період невизначеності.
Демократія залежить від довіри виборців до системи -
і на виборах  до Бундестагу восени німці продемонструють
своїм політикам, кому і наскільки вони довіряють.